user authentication there are two main
ways to get the job done
sessions and tokens the traditional
approach on the web is cookie-based
server-side sessions the process begins
with a user filling out their username
and password and then submitting it to a
server which then validates it creates a
session in the database
then responds with a session id the
session id will be saved in the
browser's cookie jar
which is a place in the browser to save
key value pairs that will be sent back
to the server on each subsequent request
it can then respond back with content
designed for the currently logged end
user
in other words we have a stateful
session between the front end client
and backend server this approach works
great but there are some drawbacks it
can be vulnerable to an attack known as
cross-site request forgery where the
attacker points the user to a site
they're logged into to perform
actions they didn't intend to like
submitting a payment or changing their
password
although the risk is very low especially
if you use a modern framework to
implement your code the bigger problem
is that you'll need to store the session
id
in a database or keep it in memory on
the server because most of today's
cloud applications are scaled
horizontally this can be a huge
bottleneck in production
and that brings us to token-based
authentication which solves this problem
but introduces its own set of challenges
the process begins the same with the
client sending its login details to the
server instead of storing a session id
it generates a json web token the jot is
created with a private key on the server
then it's sent back to the browser where
it's normally kept in local storage
on future requests the jot will be added
to the authorization header
prefixed by bearer the server then only
needs to validate the signature there's
no need for a database lookup somewhere
else in the infrastructure
and that's way more efficient when
dealing with a distributed system in the
cloud
however tokens can still be hijacked by
an attacker and they can also be
difficult to invalidate
and they can't be used to authenticate a
user in the background on the server
here's the most important thing to
understand with a session the
authentication state is handled on the
server
while tokens are managed on the client
this has been user authentication in 100
seconds
if you want to master web security check
out web security academy
my friend bartos is launching a 12-week
coaching program
it's not your ordinary course but 12
weeks of high-value group-based learning
and i'm teaching my own module in the
course on firebase security check out
the link in the description to learn
more and i will see you there in a few
weeks thanks for watching